welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and it's time to
put a smile on that face with a full
plotly breakdown of Joker I put together
this entire story from the script that
was leaked last year as well as some of
the newly confirmed details that we have
in a recent interview Todd Phillips did
say that some details had changed from
the initial script leak and there would
still be some surprises but on the whole
things are quite similar
now all leaks like this should be taken
with a pinch of salt and now we won't be
able to confirm if this is right or
wrong until we see the movies for
ourselves these line up a lot with
trailers and behind-the-scenes footage
so it makes a lot of sense from here on
out its full spoilers ahead so if you
don't want anything about the film
potentially room for you then I highly
suggest that you turn off now with that
all the way I just want to give a huge
thank you for clicking this video now
let's get into my breakdown of Joker
okay so the first thing you need to know
is that the movie is set in 1981 Gotham
which is when the city is at its lowest
point due to a seemingly unending crime
wave in addition to this there's a
garbage strike which means that Gotham
is pretty dirty both literally and
figuratively and the recent trailer that
was released we did see that there were
trash bags pile up in alleyways
everywhere and this seems to line up a
lot with what we know so far the film
itself follows the rise of arthur flack
who is initially just a clown for a
talent agency flack has severe mental
health issues that include laughing when
he's nervous and because of this a
social worker keeps a close eye on him
black wishes to become a stand-up comic
but due to his nerves his sets are often
ruined and thus he never really gets
anywhere one day he's assaulted and his
friend tells him to get a gun for
protection
Arthur develops a crush on his neighbor
played by ZZ beats a single mom who
works in a bank and he begins stalking
her she treats him well out of pity
which he missed constructs his genuine
affection in addition to this Fleck is a
caretaker for his mother who just so
happens to be a former housekeeper of
Wayne Manor the household headed up by
Thomas Wayne is currently in the
spotlight because Wayne is running for
mayor those who read Batman earth-1 will
remember that in that Thomas was running
for mayor against the penguin and that
the character was killed for it so that
the miniature crime boss
come elected and control the city
however this doesn't seem to be popping
up here and the main conflict seems to
be between Wayne and the city itself
flex mother is obsessed with the mayoral
candidate and apparently Wayne fired her
from working at his property because of
this in the film Thomas does get elected
and people begin protesting against him
for neglecting the poor black desperate
for money takes a new job but after he's
mocked in the subway he cracks slightly
and violently kills three Wall Street
guys who were also harassing a young
woman and these murders inspire resist
movement against Gotham's wealth easily
basically this film will center around
the poor uprising against the rich
similar to The Dark Knight Rises and due
to this Thomas Wayne who is viewed as
the voice of the wealthy becomes a
target during this time Arthur's mother
has an episode and is taken to Arkham
Asylum and Arthur also discovers his
neighbor has a boyfriend which causes
him to have a violent outburst at the
bank she works out which gets it fired
it's at this point that Arthur tries his
hand at stand-up comedy once more but he
completely bombs so badly that the
footage of his performance is picked up
by Murray Franklin a TV show host played
by Robert De Niro who completely
ridicules the character making him a
national joke now in the original pot
leak it was stated that police are
investigating Arthur for the murders
committed earlier which is when he
apparently stumbles across a pretty
major revelation in his mother's letters
to Thomas Wayne she claims that they had
an affair and the Arthur is the
illegitimate son of Thomas thus making
Bruce Wayne and the Joker related
however the new details from the plot
have stayed that this is in fact a lie
orchestrated by Arthur's crazy mother as
a last-ditch attempt to get Thomas to
pay attention to her Arthur will
throughout some of the movie believe
that he is in fact Bruce's brother
however when he discovers the truth he
goes completely off the deep end
repressed memories of Arthur's childhood
re-emerge and he remembers that when he
was a child he was abused by his
mother's boyfriend who actually turns
out to be his real father
at this point Arthur goes to Arkham
Asylum and kills his mother and he's
also invited on the Maury Franklin show
as a guest Joker
appears on the show shooting Franklin in
the head
delivering his speech to rile up Gotham
City he fully embraces the Joker persona
during this and from this point onward
is seen in full costume for the rest of
the movie this is of course pretty
similar to the scene from the Dark
Knight Returns in which Joker kills a
chat show host before going on a rampage
and in the film he goes out murders
people who wronged him throughout the
film however he spares zzs character now
we had heard rumors that the movie ends
with Thomas and Martha Wayne being
gunned down however the new pot leaks
suggests it's after this speech that it
happens this is because Joker sends the
city into a riot due to his words and
attackers kill the Wayne's during the
uprising even going to Wayne Manor to
kill them directly is some back and
forth on this however with some leaks
thing that they're gunning down in an
alley while others say that it's at
Wayne Manor and the one that centers
around Wayne Manor Bruce scared of
what's going on runs out of the mansion
and off into the night which is when he
falls into the cave thus setting up what
will happen in the future with the
character he's found by Alfred and a
couple of days later he heads to their
memorial which is when he encounters
Joker Joker has been on the run for
several days but with police looking
over Wayne they notice him and begin to
go after him the police chase officer
who got them but they finally managed to
catch him after he's hit by a taxi and
the movie ends with the character in
Arkham Asylum dancing around his cell
maniacally to health and John's Bennie
and the Jets now in the new leaks that
have been going around many people have
stayed that the film ends rather
ambiguously with there being a hint that
Joker might not have even committed the
things in the film and that they may
have been all in his imagination as we
did see in the trailer that he kisses
Easybeats character but this is
apparently just a fantasy
this does however tie back to the Joker
as a character most notably The Killing
Joke in which the character says if he
going to have a past why not make him
multiple choice
meaning that this could have been his
origin story or perhaps it's something
completely different
I'm normally against the Joker getting
an origin story as I do tend to believe
that he's a force of nature that
shouldn't really have one so at least
there's a nod to that in this so it
doesn't potentially break things that a
lot of people love about the
seeing it get tens across the board has
got me really hyped up for the film and
I think that it could potentially be the
best comic book movie of the year
these new leaks get me even more excited
and I can't wait to see what happens in
the film next month
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on these leaks and if you're excited for
the movie make sure you drop them in the
comments section below and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and make sure you don't forget to check
out my video that breaks down the leak
first look at Marvel's new animated
series what if I go over everything that
you need to know about the brand new
images so it's definitely worth checking
out if you want to know more if you want
to come talk to me about movies TV shows
games and comic books then you can
follow me on twitter at definition
whitey it's the best way to get in touch
with me and it's the perfect place to
suggest new videos and content so
hopefully I see you over there after
this well suggest one let you know that
we're giving away a free copy of John
week three on blu-ray and all you have
to do to be in with a chance of winning
is to like this video make sure that you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on Joker in the comment section
below the winner will be chosen at
random on September the 10th and the
blue arrow be shipped out from then
whoever gets the prize so best of luck
to everyone he takes part this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]
you
you